son Goku he's defender of the innocent
the light in the darkness and apparently
truth he's the ally too good and a
nightmare to all those who oppose him
having follows his journey from boyhood
through his teens far into adulthood
today Goku has faced a plethora of the
anime industry's most iconic villains he
is without a doubt a mascot for the
industry as well as Japan as a country
but that's not the last feather in
Goku's cap either
he is also universe sevens strongest
fighter but how strong you see and is
there a way to find out well that's what
we're here to find out today using as
much official reference as I can muster
together I will try and find out just
how strong son Goku is he's our main man
G that Dawn's the orange key I'm totally
not mark and this is the power level
series episode seven son Goku 10k yes
boo it's your turn today - son Goku is a
member of the warrior race known as
Saiyans he is four years old when you
take into account the time he has spent
dead and the time you spent in the
hyperbolic time chamber his techniques
and transformations include the kaio-ken
spirit bomb kamehameha instant
transmission Super Saiyan one two three
and Super Saiyan blue there are 11
officially stated power levels for Goku
those being 10 180 260 910 334 416 924
over 8,000 180,000 3 million and 150
million our journey with this entry
begins with episode 1 of Dragon Ball Z
where we are reintroduced to our main
character Goku as he visits calm a house
accompanied by his first born child son
gohan with that first episode those that
watched Dragon Ball choir were hit by a
bombshell that opened up the entire
universe to our cast of characters Goku
was an alien a member of a near extinct
warrior race known as sane this
exposition was presented to Goku by his
brother Raddatz he explained that Goku
when he initially arrived on planet
earth was supposed to have laid waste to
the planet so that they could sell it
later Raddatz however notices that Goku
has not done his job and so kidnaps his
son in the hopes that it would persuade
Goku to join them in other planet piracy
missions naturally this is not an option
for Goku and for the first time in the
series
request the help of longtime enemy
piccolo once both Goku and piccolo land
on the battlefield to confront Raddatz
we learn of their respective power
levels weighted and unweighted wages
Goku at this time has a power level of
334
however as stays above this is just his
restraint power level once unencumbered
by his weighted clothing Goku's power
shoots up to 416 at this level of power
Goku is still no match for Raddatz who
at this time has a battle power of 1500
more than enough for both of them
however thanks to some special tricks
from piccolo Gohan's blind sided attack
and the ultimate sacrifice from Goku
Raddatz was defeated left to die on the
open fields of earth Raddatz as a
character existed purely for exposition
and to act as a means to connect Goku to
the rest of the universe while weak
comparatively to the fighters that would
come when we first met him he was an
imposing force and most importantly gave
us our first official reference for
power levels in this series using these
new devices known as Scouters and with
this Scouter Raddatz for goals the
necessary information to both NASA and
Vegeta who now desire to use the Earth's
Dragon Balls
to wish for their own immortality
between the events of the Raddatz saga
and the seine invasion one year later
Goku dies on the battlefield alongside
his brother and thanks to his heroic
efforts in defense of his planet on
numerous occasions he was granted the
use of his body to travel to the
legendary King Kai's planet but first he
has to traverse the seemingly unending
snake way taking the pass aliens were to
arrive one year later as literal as
possible
that would mean if King Kai's estimates
that Goku had around 158 days worth of
training until the same invasion was
correct that would mean that Goku travel
snake way in about 207 days that's a
long run Goku initially frets as to
whether or not that's enough time to
train to which King Kai assure is that
it is saying that 158 days of training
here is worth thousands of years on
earth so during this time period Goku
trains intensely on King Kai's planet
learning the spirit bomb and the
kaio-ken techniques moves that would
prove to be invaluable for the remainder
of his life to date but that's not all
he also increases his power enormous Lee
in that time from a one-time max of 416
to over 8,000
this is revealed to us by Vegeta who
informs nappa of Goku's power level as
you all know goku goes on to break that
was back when he decides to attack
it's a pretty awesome shot actually
which leads to her introduction to
Vegeta's more ruthless and merciless
nature literally blasting his longtime
companion to pieces
what follows is one of the most iconic
standoffs in anime history the
lower-class commoner facing off against
the super elite Prince Vegeta at this
time this series has an officially
stated power level of 18,000 when going
all-out again completely a class in
Goku's current maximum output of just
over 8,000 however thanks to King Kai's
tutelage Goku has master move that
vastly improves his power and speed
output in short bursts the kaio-ken
technique using an ill-advised x 3 boost
Goku is able to gain control of the
fight boosting his power to 24,000 when
using the kaio-ken times 3 it's worth
noting here that seeing as Goku required
to use the Kyle Ken times for Vegeta's
Galica and most outputs somewhere in the
region of 24,000 in power in that
instance using the times for kaio-ken
multiplier Goku's power explodes to
32,000 easily overpowering Vegeta's best
efforts this is the first of many
occasions Goku truly humbles the same
prince vegeta infuriated with what is
transpiring pulls out his trump card his
last resort
his o's are formed fun fact videos
oozaru formed has a power level of
180,000 when you take into account it
has a base multiplier of times 10 if
Goku was outmatched that was ro he would
need a kaio-ken multiplier of at least
times 23 which is a higher multiplier
than Goku has attempted in any part of
the series of long history probably for
good reason to the events of this fight
are well documented throughout the
community nothing else of note occurs
during the rest of this battle as it
pertains to Goku strength once Vegeta is
defeated by the forces of Earth Goku is
transported to a hospital where he
pretty much waits for a sense of being
from Corrin
once the sense of being is consumed Goku
breaks from his bandages and makes a
beeline for Planet Namek and this is
where things get a little absurd or at
least I think they do anyway this
highlights how truly impossible it is to
predict how strong a character would be
when official reference isn't available
Goku while using the gravity chamber
spaceship designed by boas father
travels to Planet Namek now there is no
way to infer how strong Goku became
right after he ate that sensor beam
there is no means to measure a Zheng Kai
for him at this point however we do know
that in the past go
has increased in strength once recovered
from battle from his vampire of 8,000
facing Vegeta - when he arrives on
Planet Namek his base power increases to
90,000 which is even more incredible
when you take into account that the trip
dynamic was only six days this all means
that from the Zheng Kai after Padilla's
fight and the training on his way to
Namak Goku increased his power just over
eleven times which is more than King
Kai's training did for him in a hundred
and fifty-eight days and that was with
the tutelage of someone who was stronger
than him on the sixth day cinnamic he
trained in solitude but I suppose we'll
have to make it down to the gravity
chamber training he did on his way to
Namak we have to once he arrives on the
planet goku demonstrates that he can
easily boost his power significantly
higher than captain ginyu using the
kaio-ken technique in this particular
scene he increases it to 180,000 far
exceeding captain canoes current max
output of 120 thousand antics ensue
which lead to Goku no longer having his
body and then getting his body back only
severely injured this is an interesting
way to take Goku out of commission for a
while without him technically losing any
credibility as a fighter I mean if you
think about it Goku didn't lose a single
fight on Namek this creates anticipation
for when Goku the only main character to
never having been defeated anomic
finally comes face to face with the
series big bad Lord Frieza once Goku
arrives on the battlefield to confront
him every other character has been put
through hell by this monster Gohan
Crillon and piccolo have all had to come
back from the brink of death and
unfortunately once Goku arrives Frieza
delivers the final blow to the Saiyan
Prince marking Vegeta's first death in
the series standing before Frieza Goku
has an officially stated power level of
3 million at this time which means the
zentai he received from the rejuvenation
tank was a multiplier of almost 34 times
those blowing has already preposterous
training results from his trip dynamic
out of the water by simply sitting there
and healing things quickly take a turn
for the worse for Goku as he is brutally
outmatched by freezes most my news
efforts forcing him to throw caution to
the wind using the kaio-ken with a
multiplier of x 20 causing his power to
skyrocket to that of 60 million or 50%
of freezes full power however this was
all in a failing effort feeling
desperate goku goes for his last resort
moon the spirit bomb which incredibly
Frieza survives and not only that once
emerging from the crater of Goku's
creation with a single blast brings
piccolo to the brink of death and blows
up Goku's longtime friend and companion
Krillin this causes him to tip over the
edge in anger and rage leading to
possibly the most iconic moment in all
of anime history
Goku's fulfillment of an ancient alien
prophecy transforming into the legendary
super saiyan and thanks to the official
guidebooks we know that the Super Saiyan
multiplier is times fifty frigging Goku
up to one hundred and fifty million when
fighting full powered freezer on the
doomed namekian world it's important to
mention at this point that any power
level I mentioned prior to this was
supplied by official resources from here
on in I will be going off the beaten
trail trying to determine what his power
level could be using as many references
to the original material and creator I
can find that's right it's time for some
good old-fashioned mental gymnastics in
previous videos I discussed why it's
possible that trunks could in fact be
stronger than Goku was after he
initially transformed into a super
saiyan on Namek my reasons ranged from
him being better practiced in the form
and that he was facing a more powerful
Frieza now that he had mechanical
enhancements so I settled on a figure of
175 million plus four trunks whence
cocoon lands trunks request to speak
with him in private
there he decides to test Goku strength
after some brief swordplay with Goku
trunks is really impressed so if at the
very least one must admit that Goku is
no stronger having spent a year healing
which in and of itself incurs a zenkai
boost
however alongside that it's also very
likely he trained and perhaps increased
his base power level thus yielding a
higher power output once the times fifty
Super Saiyan multiplier was applied long
story short Goku is stronger than trunks
in this scene and trunks had just easily
taken out a more fearsome freezer it
seems reasonable to think Goku might
have a power level of at least 200
million as a Super Saiyan around this
time to reach such a level would require
a base power level of around 4 million I
don't think the difficulty suggests he
managed to improve 33% in one year
having been 3 million in base form when
he fought Frieza lass on top of that
considering in the case of Vegeta
then Chi boosts usually range on average
from 25 to 33 percent assuming that he
is at least this strong now seems like a
fairly it's important to take into
account also that Goku during this year
spent a certain amount of time healing
and first
acting the Instant Transmission
technique after training for three years
with much weaker partners like Gohan and
piccolo Goku makes his way to the
battlefield to confront the Android at
this point in Goku story his level is
very hard to pin down suffering from the
heart virus has its setbacks in my end -
it seems clearly before Goku is even
fighting he is feeling the effects of
the virus losing breath some exertions
that would otherwise never have bothered
him this has a direct effect on his
power level and as a result isn't
fighting as strong as he would if he
were healthy this is evident due to
fighters like piccolo being able to
easily take care of Android 20 piccolo
strength at this point has been likened
to that of a Super Saiyan if you
remember so with Goku fighting hurt it's
impossible to infer what his level is
here earlier we agreed that Vegeta came
back with a power level of around 300
million in a losing effort against
Android 18 the blow statement is a clear
indicator that when he is healthy goku
is well above 200 million but less than
or equal to 300 million a quote from
Gohan during his training with his
father in the time chamber reveals that
training with someone who is
substantially weaker than your max does
slow down the stronger person's
progression and improvement so saying
that Goku while training with weaker
opponents increased by maybe 50% is as
close an estimate I could find given the
limited amount of information that I
have once recovered from the heart virus
go whose next major increase comes from
the time chamber with Gohan when inside
both Gohan and Goku achieved full
mastery of the Super Saiyan form
otherwise known as full power in Super
Saiyan or Super Saiyan grade for
surpassing both trunks and Vegeta's
efforts in the chamber Goku powering up
to half around this time is enough to
throw Vegeta into a rage spouting about
how Kakarot can continually widen the
gap between them this means that Goku
while using half of his current power
can surpass Vegeta's max output in this
newly acquired super saiyan grade 4 form
Goku must have a full power level
somewhere in the region of 2.5 billion
give or take seeing as we have already
established that Vegeta at this time has
a par level in the region of 1.25
billion we had discussed both Gohan and
Vegeta at length during this period also
the advantage of doing so makes placing
Goku relatively easy he is at this point
between Vegeta and go Han but much
closer to Gohan strength when in Super
Saiyan grade 4 and with that out of the
way Goku doesn't get any more noteworthy
power-ups for the rest of the arc until
the Buu saga comes around which means
there is a seven-year time skip as I
previously explained in Maya
video regarding Vegeta Vegeta when he
had his power unlocked by bhavati had a
power that could have been higher than
Gohan when he was facing cell which we
have already established as being 5
billion from my last Gohan video using
this we can infer that Vegeta around
this time is in the neighborhood of 5.5
billion give or take in order for us to
move forward let's assume that Goku was
using the Super Saiyan 2 transformation
to his full potential when fighting
Vegeta which would place them pretty
evenly in that form both fighting with a
power level in the range of 5 point 5 to
6 billion
fun fact Google has never defeated
Vegeta in a one-on-one fight on screen
in the series today Goku has fought his
longtime rival on two separate occasions
not include inspiring and training
sessions the first being during the same
invasion of Earth which if the other Z
fighters didn't intervene would have
surely meant Goku's death at the hands
of a Vegeta in his Ozar roof on the
second during the boosts ugh granted
Goku was holding back the vast majority
of his power but that's his fault and
Vegeta beat him with the Hey look over
there move combined with a clubbing blow
to the back of the head so let's assume
Goku is in the region of 5.5 billion
around this time period in this super
saiyan 2 form therefore if we apply the
times for multiplier of the super saiyan
3 on to the super saiyan to form go
whose full power skyrockets to 22
billion and with that I think it's time
for now yes boom it's your turn go to
take five it's time for a quick
breakdown of the mysterious majin buu
majin buu is a majin not sure if that's
a race as approximately 5 million years
old his techniques include the chocolate
beam body manipulation and regeneration
margin kamehameha and healing and there
are no officially stated power levels
for majin buu this is going to be good
while there are many iterations of majin
buu throughout the saga i will be
focusing on the ones that pertain
specifically to the fat good food that
we ultimately get in Dragon Ball super
those being the innocent food we get
initially and the good booth at Kid Buu
purges from this system so let's begin
with innocent poop the history of
innocent Buu is long and convoluted but
I will try to keep it as concise as I
can over 5 million years ago the evil
wizard bibbidi bobbidi z' father created
a destructive entity void of reason or
emotion called boo he lived to only
destroy and slow her other life-forms
which led to the destruction of hundreds
of worlds during that time however the
Kai's saw to his containment
and so he was contained for five million
years however because of Goku and
Vegeta's fighting enough energy was
collected to open the seal and release
the innocent majin buu on a number of
occasions various fighters are duped by
margin booze power thinking that he's
less than he actually is
however before booze suddenly became two
separate entities goku referring to the
innocent pooh suggested that he might
have been able to beat him there are a
ton of quotes to consider I'll flash
them on screen for anyone that wants to
read them in their own time but the
general gist of it is majin buu isn't an
ordinary opponent and that his power
level is almost like a life before boom
split in two the good and evil Super
Saiyan 3 Goku was perhaps a little
stronger
however Goku knows that his ki can be
deceiving so if we were to lowball the
innocent majin buu that initially came
from the sealed pod his power must be up
in the region of 22 billion with Super
Saiyan 3 Goku however it should be noted
that margin booze power can fluctuate
hugely depending on his temperament and
mood for the sake of finding a general
figure let's take 22 billion as the
average alright so time for a breakdown
of what happens with majin buu hmm it
isn't boost bits into good booty Babu
gets into every evil room he comes to a
room and then there's lots of ooze time
passes in kid do or pure Buu purge
themselves of the good boom to get all
that No well let me go back and cover
the only part that's important when
majin buu split into two it created a
good boot and an evil the evil Buu
receives majority of the power though
both are not as strong as the combined
innocent Buu was prior the only estimate
I have to go off of in terms of power
scale for the combined innocent Buu was
that he was perhaps around the same
strength as Super Saiyan 3 Goku the good
boo is what we are concerned with here
today so given that he was able to fight
with him for a little while it's fair to
assume that he didn't get completely
outdone in the power department I'll be
generous and give him 40 percent of the
combined power we already established
that Super Saiyan 3 would be in the
region of 22 billion at this time and so
40 percent of that is 8.8 billion
also at the time the evil majin buu or
the grave ooh had the remainder of the
power which means that he must have had
a power of thirteen point two billion
receiving the remainder of the innocent
boos power was absorbed by the evil
great boot they become Super Buu who
because of his body type is a more adept
fighter and therefore more dangerous
than the prior innocent Buu incarnation
the good boo has a few more good
showings throughout the rest of the arc
but none which alter his power from the
beginning of super up until the
and the Future Trunks arc boo is seen
eating getting owned by beerus and
failing an exam there was however an
instance that came about during my
writing for this episode majin buu was
seen to be training two hours worth of
it to be exact and in those two hours
according to Goku improved greatly we're
marking on his speed among other things
however there wasn't enough information
to go off of to derive an estimated
figure or at least I don't think there
was only time will reveal how strong our
pink Genie friend is in truth really and
so knowing this I will put majin buu
significantly greater than 8.8 billion
so I'll leave a plus next to the figure
majin buu is a being of magic which
makes measuring his power and almost
impossibility in many respects it seems
to waver on his mood as well as its
motivation that said with his unique
moveset I am very excited to see what
this little pink blob brings to the
tournament now back to Goku before I get
under super I want to address a
particular quote by one Akira Toriyama
when referring to the battle of gods
movie in 2013 it reads I suppose that
beers as strengths of the ten Super
Saiyan God will be right about a six
only sans rapidly increase in strength
as they fight against strong opponents
so the longer they fought the more the
gap would shrink and it might even be
possible for them to eventually turn the
tables incidentally I guess we could be
about a 15 however in that very same
interview moments later he was asked
about the future of the series to which
he replied to be honest I haven't given
it any thought at all the 610 15 power
scaling was quoted by Toriyama when he
had no plans of the series ever
continuing bear in mind this was long
before Dragon Ball super first episode
almost two years before in fact
therefore in my opinion to take this
into consideration would be a falsehood
as it comes from a time where Toriyama
wasn't considering anything other than a
movie now back to super firstly
regarding the resurrection of f mark a
point of fierce contention is of when
goku fights a new and improved fourth
form Frieza in his base form and wins on
top of that
however while scaling this encounter is
a mere impossibility due to freezes
insane power increase there is a reason
that exists as to why Goku can fight
Frieza in that form the theory goes as
follows after Goku attained the super
saiyan god transformation through ritual
he fought bears intensely
however the god form had a time limit
causing the form to fade having faded
Goku retained all the strength from the
Super Saiyan God form and absorbed
into his base therefore seeing at the
resurrection of f ark takes place after
the events of battle of gods it's fair
to assume that Goku while fighting
Frieza was using his god essence that he
absorbed during the battle with beerus
god power is still very much up in the
air as to how it works exactly in my
last episode detailing Vegeta's life I
explained my process in detail as to how
I came up with lord beerus as
ever-rising powerlab while also
explaining that beerus is as strong as
the series allows and that there are
currently no plans for Goku and Vegeta
to surpass beers and weeks or at least
that is my knowledge as of right now so
if you'd like to see how I derived an
estimate for beerus is full power level
go check out my last video about Vegeta
I leave a link in the description down
below alrighty and so with that out of
the way beerus i estimated as being in
the region of 245 quintillion and that
super saiyan blue vegeta
after the Future Trunks ark was around 8
percent of beerus as total power but
before we use that let's take a look at
this is word Drago's power is increased
after absorbing the super saiyan god
power training with vegeta under Wiese
three years in hyperbolic time chamber
with vegeta more training with weeks
seeing as vegeta super saiyan blue form
was stronger than goku z' towards the
end of the Future Trunks Ark I will put
Goku at 6% of beerus which is far than
the 8% the Vegeta has in his super
saiyan blue form giving goku a power
level in the region of fourteen point
seven quintillion when in his super
saiyan blue form at the end of the
Future Trunks arc however and this is a
big however because Goku was able to
combine the efforts of the Super Saiyan
blue form with the Kaioken he is capable
of pushing his power far beyond his
regular limits the most dramatic of
which took place during the tournament
between universe 6 and universe 7 where
go ku while fighting against hit used a
kaio-ken multiplier of x 10 in his super
saiyan blue state resulting in enormous
power but before we look at doing basic
multiplication we need to figure out
whether or not Goku has improved since
the end of the Future Trunks arc do you
see him doing actual work towards the
beginning of the universe survival arc
and along with that it's even implied
that he's gotten rusty
however a little later in that arc Goku
is seen to be trading with Wiese
deflecting a blast from him while in his
regular super saiyan state now what's
important to note regarding the scene we
have never seen Goku take a blast from
we
before we do not know how much wheezes
trying and we do not know if any
substantial amount of time has passed so
taking that into account I'll increase
them slightly turn even 15 quintillion
with that while using the kaio-ken times
10 his power would shoot up to 150
quintillion and that's pretty much Goku
the Dragonball series as a whole can
mean many different things to a lot of
different people for some it can be
escapism I know a lot of people use it
as inspiration and most use it simply as
something you can just sit down every
week and enjoy and that's the key right
there it's something to enjoy Akira
Toriyama didn't have a grand plan for
the story he rarely had anything timed
at all improvising from issue to issue a
lot of the time Dragon Ball has never
pretended to be anything that it isn't
and it was never about the details or
the finer points it's about a young boy
who through many adventures and fierce
battles gains companionship and strength
into his adult life is there to make
people laugh and to get you to cheer on
your favorite characters when they're in
the heat of battle nothing more about
two months ago when I began creating
this series I never imagined it would
get so much attention this was just a
fun excuse for me to sit down and retell
the story of Dragon Ball from the
perspective of my favorite characters
it's really fun to look back at these
moments while trying to piece together
using logic when answers simply aren't
there at all so in saying that these are
by no means official color readings and
judging by how unpredictable the series
is I don't think it's possible to derive
any accurate power readings from this
story but that was never the point I had
an absolute blast navigating the Dragon
Ball timeline with you guys but before I
go I would like to ask you what you
think I missed in this series how strong
do you think all the fires are going to
be once the tournament comes around with
all that said I hope you enjoyed these
short videos I've been working on these
past two months I would like to thank
anyone who contributed by sharing
commenting and liking this series I've
been totally not mark and as always
thank you so much for watching